toute la philosophie du film était
d'essayer de tout filmer à huis clos,
nous avons donc décidé qu'il était logique de construire une
version à grande échelle du bateau à bulles
une fois que vous avez des difficultés, vous pouvez aller
n'importe où sauf la poutre de queue ou vous pouvez
faire  le cockpit l'avez-vous mis dedans nous
obtenons enfin la bulle
livrable c'est la première fois qu'elle est
assemblée
nous avons passé une heure et demie à créer
et à trouver toutes les pièces c'est comme
le matin de Noël alors nous en sortons tout
le paquet est vous savez le film à
bulles aucune des antennes dans cette
chose quelles sont vos prochaines étapes tous ces
goujons se montent sur la plaque dessus
allez-y vos doigts allez-y revenez en arrière et nous
reviendrons hier soir déposez-le avec le
déjeuner je n'ai pas  idée de ce que va
être cet homme que je tremble en ce moment
être capable en tant que designer de participer
à un film où ils construisent de vrais
véhicules c'est le rêve d'un designer devenu
réalité tout est entièrement assemblé maintenant
nous travaillons juste pour obtenir les lumières
sapin  préparé pour ce soir pour Tom et Joe
ouais c'est beau cette chose nous
avons ouvert les portes point dieu c'est
beau puis-je entrer Tom Cruise était
super impliqué dans tout ce qu'il est venu
dans les ateliers où nous avons construit
obtenir des commentaires sur les commandes pour
s'assurer  c'était aussi réaliste que possible
avec les pédales et le manche de commande,
il est si joliment conçu que chaque
pièce était juste un estomac lisse et élégant,
c'était vraiment excitant de
partager ce moment avec lui le travail les gars
il y a quelques incarnations différentes
du bateau à bulles  nous avons le
vaisseau à bulles complet et nous avons essentiellement juste
le cockpit sur un cardan basé sur le mouvement complet,
donc nous aurons tous les
chasseurs volants, puis les effets visuels nous
mettrons le reste du vaisseau à l'arrière
de ce prêt ouais
tom est un  pilote lui-même donc il est très à l'
aise avec tout ce mouvement on va
un peu plus vite mais n'a jamais été sur une
sorte de cardan comme ça avant Oh mademoiselle
fiez vous à la télé ouais d'accord Abbi Olga vous dira
toi aujourd'hui, elle n'avait pas peur amuse-toi oh mon
Dieu, elle avait peur que
le bateau à bulles soit une belle création
quand il est juste debout sur le sol
mais tu ne veux pas être là quand
il se retourne
à la fin j'aime bien avoir  de l'
admettre mais ne le dites à personne j'ai
prétendu que je n'avais pas fait du bon travail elle est
très courageuse elle a enduré et sa
performance du film n'a pas de prix
parce que c'est réel ça ne va pas
bien